today we'll be ranking top 20 strongest
characters in one piece we'll start with
one of the strongest Admirals kizaru and
in the later parts of the video we'll be
covering some of the strongest
characters that are on par with Legends
barcelino more commonly known by azaleas
kizaru is an admiral in the Marines
befitting his Admiral status kizaru's
physical prowess is immense his raw
strength was enough for him to trade
equal blows with the Elder Rayleigh and
even engage Whitebeard himself face to
face generally kizaru's melee attack
style emphasizes incredibly heavy kicks
via his ability to move at the speed of
light allowing him to easily demolish
entire buildings and incapacitate
Pirates of noticeable skill with a
single blow kizaru ate the pika pika no
me a logia type devil fruit that allows
him to create control and transform his
body into light he's also able to
perform kicks at the speed of light
shoot laser beams and blind his
opponents during the summit work izaru
fought several strong pirates on equal
footing however Whitebeard and Marco
were the only pirates that prompted the
Admiral to fight somewhat seriously he
was Ultimate definitely one of the few
people to emerge from the war wholly
unscathed not a mark to show for it
after each character will also predict
how strong they'll be by the end of the
series and you'll definitely be
surprised by some of the results in
kizaru's case I don't really think
you'll get much stronger than he
currently is so his place will stay the
same also if you stick to the end of
this video I'll share an interesting
fact about Shanks that 95 percent of
people don't know number 19. aokiji
alkiji is a former Marine Admiral and
the first one to be revealed in the
manga arguably the greatest yet
Testament to his strength is his duel
against Akainu in this battle he matched
his extremely strong adversary for a
total of 10 days until he suffered his
defeat his attack speed is notable as
well with him managing to intercept
whitebeard's quake-powered naginata
mid-swing by fully encapsulating its
wielder and Ice against doflamingo he
proved fast and stealthy enough to sneak
up on him taking his back without the
warlord noticing until aokiji spoke he
then prevented him from dealing a
killing blow to Smoker by icing him up
faster than he could move his hand while
leaving smoker untouched before his loss
against Akainu aokiji was considered to
be the strongest Marine Admiral
therefore he deserves the 19th spot on
the list right above kizaru also I don't
think he'll get any important power-ups
so his place should be the same at the
end of the series there are still 18
incredibly strong characters left to
cover and the next one is Almighty
kizuki Odin even when he was nine Odin
was already such a skilled swordsman
that he waged war against the entire
Yakuza and was able to fight against
them all by himself at the age of 10 he
was eventually arrested for almost
killing someone when he grew up in his
interaction with Whitebeard Odin took a
point-blank quake punch from Whitebeard
straight to the face and was fine
afterwards additionally he held on to a
chain pulled by the Moby Dick and faced
many dangers and climates of the new
world ocean with no protection for three
days before eventually letting go more
because he went to rescue Toki than due
to exhaustion prior to his prime when he
met Roger and got hit by his Divine
departure Odin got back up immediately
with only minor injuries in the anime
during his fight against kaido Odom was
hit by his blast breath not just once
but twice empowered through them both
times as a testament to his monstrous
strength and endurance Odom was able to
hold up all nine of his retainers on a
thick wooden plank while his lower half
was submerged in a large pot of boiling
oil for over an hour an unprecedented
Thief that impressed even kaido since
Odin was able to hold his ground against
kaido and would possibly even win if he
wasn't distracted by Higurashi he
certainly deserves to be placed above
Admirals since Odin is already dead is
placed at the end of the series would
obviously stay the same number 17.
Rayleigh Prime Silver's Rayleigh also
known as the dark King is an extremely
powerful and famous retired pirate who
formerly served as the first Maid of the
legendary Roger Pirates shakuyaku stated
that he was 100 times stronger than all
of the 11 supernovas by the time they
first arrived in the sabaudi archipelago
rayleigh's tremendous battle prowess
allowed him to fight on par with Admiral
kizaru preventing him from attacking the
straw hat Pirates however Rayleigh
himself has admitted that he is not as
young as he used to be and as a result
can Tire in battle this means that in
his prime he was probably much stronger
than when he fought it's really
difficult to say if Rayleigh was
stronger than Odin in his prime but
since he was Roger's first mate we'll
put him higher on the list but frankly
it can go either way number 16. big mom
Charlotte lindlin better known as big
mom is the captain of the big mom
Pirates as she was one of the four
Emperors she was considered to be one of
the four strongest pirates in the world
when her former fellow Emperor kaido
threatened to kill her she came to his
territory big bomb simply invited him to
try and said he wouldn't be able to
dissuade her even the straw hat Pirates
recognized that she could crush them
quickly and easily if they bought her
recklessly linlin acquired the powers of
the Soto Soto no me after eating its
previous owner Carmel this is the only
known devil fruit power that was
acquired through the means of
cannibalism this fruit allows her to
manifest people's Souls as an ethereal
substance that she can grab hold of so
long as the intended victim feels fear
she can then steal the soul from the
victim taking away their lifespan by an
amount of her choosing once she has them
big bomb can Infuse the stolen Souls
into objects to give them life turning
them into beings called homies which act
as her servants she can also consume her
own soul in order to make herself bigger
and stronger big mom also possesses
immense Mastery in the uses of how Shoku
haki she was first seen using it at
Sanji and pudding's wedding and was
later seen again when she fought with
kaido at onigashima The Clash of their
house shokuhaki was powerful enough to
cause a massive shock wave that split
the sky open although big mom never
fought any of the previously mentioned
characters is one of the four Emperors
she should be stronger than them number
15. Blackbeard Blackbeard is the captain
trait admiral of the Blackbeard Pirates
and currently one of the four Emperors
by some unknown method Blackbeard became
the first and so far only known person
to be able to wield the powers of two
devil fruits at the same time with the
power of Darkness the yummy yummy Nomi
and the power of earthquakes the
guragura Nomi Blackbeard claims himself
to be truly invincible and the strongest
of them all teach also possesses
tremendous physical strength which was
demonstrated when he seriously injured
Luffy and Ace in just one hit sending
them both crashing back with Incredible
force in the anime he was shown to be
able to knock back and injure Whitebeard
with a few punches a feat that shucked
the other members of the Whitebeard
Pirates an example of his sheer
endurance is that he took a point-blank
gear-second attack from an enraged Luffy
and was hit by sengoku in his daibutsu
form only to come out with minor
injuries both times teach also shows
incredible tolerance to pain as despite
his devil fruit increasing his pain it
never stops him for long we didn't see
much of Blackbeard since he acquired the
powers of guragura no me but it's
certain that now he's one of the
strongest characters alive therefore we
placed him above big mom Blackbeard will
probably face Luffy sometime near the
end of the series and I'm pretty sure
he'll get some pretty insane power-ups
and because of that his place on the
list would be much higher around 9th
Place number 14 Dragon the Revolutionary
Army is the group of rebels who are not
controlled by the fox moral regime of
the world government and see how it
continuously controls and ruins the
lives of the Common Man the leader of
this group is the world's worst criminal
Monkey D Dragon the man who dedicated
his life to stopping the celestial
dragons and bringing true freedom to the
world dragon's first appearance was in
Logan town where he stopped Marine
Captain smoker who previously seemed
impenetrable due to his devil fruit
Dragon casually stopped smoker from
killing his son and the Marine Captain
himself knew that he was in the presence
of a man that he clearly cannot defeat
unlike Garb and Luffy dragon is more
serious personality wise and very
focused on his goal of creating the New
World Order Dragon would save and train
Sabo Luffy's adopted brother after he
got shot and badly injured by a
Celestial Dragon this shows how
dangerous Dragon could be as he was able
to raise a fairly ordinary child into
becoming his second in command and one
of the deadliest men in all the Seas
Dragon albeit an enigma to most people
is actually known around the world due
to his active recruitment of new members
into the army although dragon is pretty
much confirmed to have weather-based
powers as of now we don't know how
strong he actually is his current place
on the list is purely a speculation and
its possibilities much stronger than
this so for the end of the series we'll
put Dragon a bit higher around 10th
Place number 13 Miha as the strongest
swordsman in the world and former rival
of Shanks mihawk is an immensely skilled
combatant he easily defeated dung
Creek's entire fleet of 50 ships and 5
000 Men by himself with only the main
ship surviving because a bad storm
pushed them away his strength is so
great that dong Creek even accused him
of having the devil fruit Powers a true
Testament to mihawk's abilities is that
after the seven Warlords of the sea were
abolished his Bounty was raised to 3
billion 590 million bellies one of the
highest Bounties in the world that even
surpasses to the current four Emperors
his Incredible strength and influence
were proven once again when buggy became
an emperor simply because the Marines
thought mihawk was serving under him in
the past he was also known as the Marine
Hunter Zorro himself admitted that even
after training with mihawk he's still
not anywhere near his level of skill as
a swordman further attesting to mihawk's
combat and fighting prowess sure do is
up at that Hawkeyes mihawk also
possesses extraordinary skill in Ken
Boon shokuhaki as he was able to easily
track Luffy's high speed Gear 2
movements and strike with extreme
precision as someone who's rivaled
Shanks in the past and fought him
multiple times without losing mihawk is
definitely on par with Emperors and
deserves his spot about the likes of big
mom and Blackbeard number 12. Luffy as
one of the four Emperors and at the
young age of 19 Luffy has proven his
physical might time and time again
having developed a significant level of
strength to match some of the world's
most powerful Fighters louvi has
utilized his gears transformation
techniques made possible by his devil
fruit powers to tremendously increase
his physical strength and subdue
powerful opponents like bluno Rob Lucy
and Don Quixote do Flamingo during the
climax of The Raid on onigashima Luffy
managed to awaken his devil fruit this
gave him the ability to transform into
the Sun God pinca after Awakening Luffy
demonstrates many new abilities such as
being able to freely manipulate the
shape and size of his body he also takes
on a more cartoonish fighting style
being able to Grant the environment
around him the same properties as rubber
which allowed him to deflect a bolo
Breath by bouncing it back at kaido
Luffy is only one of two confirmed
people in the world capable of not only
using all three form of hockey but the
advanced application of each one most
notably Silver's relay stated that he
has a noticeable talent for hockey
having mastered the basics of all forms
in only a year and a half through
fighting against and training with
powerful hockey users in the new world
Luffy strengthened his skill with each
form of hockey to a much greater degree
and became even more powerful as of now
we can't place Luffy any higher on the
list as he still didn't Master his new
abilities however in the future after
Luffy proves his might using gear fifth
he'll definitely surpass some of the
characters that are currently above him
therefore he'll probably be around
second place number 11 Akainu as with
all Admirals sakazuki's physical prowess
is immense his raw physical strength was
enough for him to go up against and
Clash evenly with Whitebeard the
strongest man in the world in close
quarters perhaps most impressive however
are sakazuki's vast durability and
endurance this is best illustrated by
how not even two successive Quake
punches from Whitebeard could keep him
down the second blows strong enough to
split the island of marine forwarding
two as as a side effect sakuzuki ate the
magamaga Nomi a logia type devil fruit
that allows him to create control and
transform his body into magma his magma
is extremely hot and highly explosive
thus making it well suited for combat
allowing sakazuki to burn melt and
Destroy anything in his path in fact
among all devil fruits sakazuki's is
said to offer the greatest attack power
akinu's primary method of combat is
transforming his arms into magma to
launch burning punches that can easily
penetrate human bodies he can also
drastically enlarge his arms to throw
forward giant magnifice meant to reach
enemies farther away although sakazuki
is vulnerable to hockey attacks the heat
his body creates has enemies heavily
discouraged from coming near and
striking and physically lest they be
burned Luffy and akinu will surely cross
paths at some point in the future and
it'll definitely be an interesting
battle to say the least at this moment
it's really hard to say which one of
them is more powerful but for now we'll
put a kainu on the 11th place with a
kainu covered we're only halfway there
and these next characters are on a
completely different level number 10
sengoku prime sengoku the Buddha is one
of the most underrated characters in the
world of one piece sengoku is a very
intelligent man he dedicated his life to
serving the Marines protecting the lives
of the innocent and extinguishing the
evil of piracy in the world he was very
good at using hockey and he also
possesses the mythical Zone type devil
fruit that allows him to transform into
the mighty and Powerful Golden Buddha
his strength is known around the world
with the likes of Roger seeing him and
his partner GARP as the only worthy
adversaries who could stand a chance
against him in a fight this would make
him one of the world government's
strongest form of offense against the
world's strongest Pirates after Roger
was captured he and GARP would stop the
pirate king from being rescued by Golden
Shiki when he broke in to recover Roger
from the Marine Ford Headquarters as the
fleet Admiral before Akainu as well as
the mythical Zone type devil fruit user
sengoku is well placed at Ninth spot
number nine shiggy shiggy was the
captain of the golden pirate crew and
during his time with them he would
become one of the most dangerous and
noteworthy captains in all the Seas
Shiki was one of Roger's greatest ride
Bibles and has battled him many times in
the past at one point Shiki even offered
Roger to form an alliance together but
Roger refused due to their different
ideals this would anger Shiki and with
the aid of his 51 commanding divisions
he attacked Roger and his crew in a
battle that would come to be known as
Edward years later after Roger got
captured Shiki couldn't believe it when
he heard the news and so he
single-handedly went all the way to the
Marine front yard demanding that he saw
Roger there he was engaged by GARP and
sengoku and was eventually defeated and
sent to impel down Shiki would defy All
Odds and be the first one to break out
of the prison but at the cost of losing
his legs Golden Lion cheeky is one of
the legendary Pirates to sail the Seas
and a vicious force that most people
would not stand a chance against in a
fight since a lot of shiki's
achievements are non-canon we can't be
sure how strong he really is but
considering that it took both GARP and
sengoku to bring him down he's
definitely at least Emperor level number
eight kaido famed as the world's
strongest creature kaido is one of the
most powerful pirates in the world
notably he has a bounty of 4 billion 600
million 100 000 bellies which is the
highest known Bounty of any pirate in
his era surpassed only by the bounties
of the Legends like Whitebeard and
Goldie Roger with a one-handed swing of
his kanabo he can send normal sized
people flying into the distance and he
broke past the tremendous defensive
power of Luffy's gear 4 with ease
sengoku once said that even a mere
Apprentice in the Rocks Pirates kaido
was able to earn the respect of his
vicious companions through his sheer
strength alone kaido's body is nigh
indestructible and even attacks
strengthened by busashoku haki can't
damage his incredibly tough skin he
received a powerful barrage of gear 4
hits from Luffy and only became sober
and felt nothing more than annoyance
receiving no injuries whatsoever as if
his Incredible strength isn't enough
kaido also possesses one of the mythical
zoan devil
fruitseryu which allows him to turn into
a giant dragon as a dragon he can
release devastating blasts of fire from
his mouth which can fully obliterate
large structures such as an entire
mountain and the castle that stood on it
kaido has mastered his devil fruit
powers to the point where he can access
some of his abilities without needing to
transform such as generating flame
clouds to levitate onigashima the reason
kaido is ranked above Luffy on this list
is simply because he's already fought a
bunch of other characters and was
wounded before engaging Luffy therefore
if he fought Luffy in his full power
it's not really clear if Luffy could
defeat him number seven Shanks
red-haired Shanks commonly known as just
red hair is the chief of the red hair
Pirates and one of the four Emperors
that rule over the new world Shinx
possesses immense physical strength as
he was once a rival to mihawk the
strongest swordsman in the world even
with only one arm Shanks can wield his
sword with immense power able to easily
match Whitebeard with his physical
strength combined with uzushoku haki
Shanks could defend against the kainu's
extremely destructive magma this Shinx
possesses fast Mastery in the usage of
how Shoku haki a rare type of hockey
that only one in several million people
in the world can use when boarding
whitebeard's main ship Shanks was
capable of knocking dozens of his men
unconscious many of whom were seasoned
Pirates able to survive the new world
also the flagship itself was damaged
from the sheer force of his presence
impressing those around him a true
Testament to his Mastery of hockey is
seen during the wano country Arc he
could send out a powerful burst of how
shokuhaki to paralyze ryokugyu while on
his ship miles outside of wano stopping
him in his tracks without even needing
to set foot in the country simply based
on this he deserves a spot above all
currently alive Emperors as for the end
of the series it's very likely that
Shanks would turn out to be much
stronger than he appears and possibly
have some secret powers we don't know
about if this turns out to be true his
place on the list would be a bit higher
around fifth place number six GARP Prime
Monkey D GARP is an extremely famous and
Powerful Marine vice admiral he's
considered a living legend and is one of
the most powerful Marines in history in
his Heyday he was famous for cornering
Goldie Roger many times as he was one of
the very few people capable of fighting
the pirate king in fact Roger states
that he and GARP had almost killed each
other many times throughout their
battles as a testament to his strength
together with Roger he fought and
defeated the Rocks Pirates the most
powerful pirate crew in history this
tremendous fee earned GARP the title
heroed the Marines as another Testament
to his sheer power GARP defeated and
nearly killed Don chinja in the past
with a single punch whose Bounty was
over 500 million bellies and was said to
be able to split a continent with a
headbutt this earned him the epithetic
GARP the fist even at the ripe age of 76
he was shown to be able to easily strike
down Mark of the Phoenix despite having
his devil fruit abilities activated at
the time which was something that both
kizaru and Akainu seemed unable to do
based on that we can't put him any lower
on the list only five more incredible
characters are left and if you already
made it this far you definitely won't
want to stop watching now number five
Whitebeard Edward Newquay more commonly
known as Whitebeard and the strongest
man in the world was the captain of the
Whitebeard pirates in his prime he stood
shoulder to shoulder with the pirate
king Goldie Roger and was capable of
fighting him to a standstill in
one-on-one combat even in his old age he
was able to effortlessly defeat Ace over
a hundred times on one occasion he was
even able to counter-attack and injure
as well sleeping during the summit
Warrior of marine Ford newgate's Health
was declining at a rapid rate but
despite this he was able to engage in
combat with aokiji kizaru and Akainu at
even terms even when on the verge of
death he was able to easily defeat
Blackbeard in two blows the world
government was prepared to use
practically the entire Marine Force plus
the seven Warlords of the sea to fight
new gate and his crew however sengoku
even remarked that their Victory
wouldn't be guaranteed due to
whitebeard's overwhelming power
Whitebeard ate the guruguru numi a
paramecia type devil fruit that allowed
him to cause Quakes and generate
powerful shock waves this power is
considered to be the strongest devil
fruit power within the paramecia class
according to sengoku Whitebeard had the
power to destroy the world his Quakes
would cause serious damage and
alterations to the surrounding landscape
he could even grab the surrounding area
itself and tilt it described as making
the entire sea tilt similarly to GARP
Whitebeard was one of Roger's biggest
Rivals and as such deserves one of the
highest places on the list number four
gold D Roger Goldie Roger was a
Legendary Pirate who is captain of the
Roger Pirates held the title of pirate
king Roger was hailed as one of the
strongest Pirates of all time if not the
strongest considered nearly Unstoppable
in battle Roger had the highest Bounty
ever in pirating history over 5 billion
500 million bellies he could also Clash
evenly with Whitebeard it's even said
that their fight once lasted for three
days and three nights straight until it
resulted in a draw Watcher also
possessed immense levels of endurance
and vitality even when his body was
ravaged by an incurable disease aided by
crocus's medical skills he managed to
conquer the grand line in a mere three
years as the only pirate king ever Roger
is undeniably one of the strongest
characters that ever lived the fact
about Shanks that I'm sharing at the end
actually happened during his first
appearance in episode 4 and I'm going to
tell you exactly what it is as soon as
we cover the last three characters on
the list number three Rock D zebic along
with Roger Rox was one of the strongest
Pirates of that era his face hasn't been
revealed yet but from his silhouette we
can see the that he had long and spiky
dreadlocks and used to wear a sailor's
coat alongside a button-shoulder belt
rocks according to all the stories about
him was a ruthless man who had great
ambition of attaining power and becoming
the king of the world he was known all
around the world as a dangerous man who
was known to cause chaos and destruction
everywhere he went the world government
wanted to put an end to him because he
continuously tried to uncover their
secrets as well as destroy the Marines
and Celestial dragons possibly his most
impressive feat is that he had three
future Emperors serving under him
Whitebeard big mom and kaido the
appearance of the D in Rock's name and
his accomplishments would make him so
dangerous to the point where he took the
Unholy Alliance of Monkey D GARP and
pirate gold D Roger to finally take him
down for good kaido even pictured zebic
alongside legendary and Powerful figures
like Shanks Odin Whitebeard and Roger
further hinting at zebex might at the
end of the day it would not be a stretch
to say Rox was arguably the strongest
and most dangerous pirate to ever live
he was the pirate King's greatest rival
and was only taken down due to the
alliance between two very powerful men
this fact May makes it clear that zedek
was definitely the strongest pirate of
his era and could easily defeat anyone
who opposed him number two emu the world
of one piece is primarily ruled by the
powerful and resourceful World
Government it owns the Marines who bring
law in order to all Seas across the
world the godose the public rulers of
the world government but they secretly
report to Inu who's the hidden puppet
master and governor of the entire
world's operation emu might rule from
the Shadows but he's aware of everything
that goes on in the world and gets all
the information he needs through the
godosei and the newspapers during emu's
first appearance he cut out photos of
Luffy Blackbeard Vivi and shirahoshi Inu
clearly wants all of them destroyed
because unknowingly to them they pose a
huge threat to the system he created in
this world it's very likely that emu
knows all the secrets of the world
including the events of the Void Century
this is why he erased most of it from
the history books and destroyed Ohara
recently in the manga we got to see what
emu is capable of in chapter 1060 we saw
emu Crossing an island of lelujia from
the map and immediately after the island
was struck by a blast from the sky
complete completely destroying it
because of this a lot of fans believe
that emu is in possession of one of the
ancient weapons Uranus if this is true
this alone would make him one of the
most dangerous characters in the series
number one Joy boy joyboy is one of the
biggest mysteries and legends of One
Piece his name would be mentioned for
the first time during the end of the
Fishman island arc when Neptune talked
to Robin after seeing her read the
apology he carved into the pony glyph
joyboy appears to have been around
during the void century and for some
unknown reason have failed to fulfill a
promise he made to the former princess
of Fishman Island and her people joyboy
is the person who located laughtail and
plays the ultimate treasure one piece
there although joyboi's appearance was
never revealed in the story he's usually
imagined by fans as a laughing giant who
wears similar straw hats to Luffy based
on the recent Revelations of the
gomagomu fruit and the reveal that it's
actually mythical Zoe and type devil
fruit it's more than likely joyboy was
the past owner of this fruit which
granted its users the power to do
anything they desire dravoy was a
companion to the island-sized elephant
zanesha and he would communicate with it
via an ability known as the voice of all
things drobo was prophesized to return
800 years after the void century and
during the third Arc of wano when Luffy
awakened his devil fruit zonesha would
tell Momo nusuke that joyboy has
returned Luffy awakened his devil fruit
very recently and didn't yet master its
power if droyboi had the same devil
fruit he was definitely way more
experienced at using it than Luffy
currently is now let's cover a fact
about Shanks that I was talking about
well at the very beginning of the anime
in episode 4 Shanks lost his arm while
saving Luffy from the Sea King however
after that Shanks just angrily looked at
the Sea King and the monster immediately
escaped this was because Shanks actually
used hockey to scare the Sea King even
though hockey would be properly
introduced hundreds of episodes later
click on this video where we covered all
11 mythical zoens in one piece what are
you waiting for click it